denise really a big day for nevada state
officials loosening restrictions
establishments which currently operate
at a 35 percent capacity
now moved up to 50 percent capacity
sally jeremiah live near decatur and
cactus
and restaurant owners been looking
forward to this for weeks months if not
the entire year sally
that's right brian and i'm here at mama
bird restaurant in southern highlands
and tell you what they have been through
so many changes
within the past year as you can imagine
implementing curbside pickup
reducing capacity and now increasing
capacity it's huge for us
we're very very happy to be able to see
more guests in our dining rooms
saks of stanley is the general manager
at mama birth southern kitchen
he says slowly but surely we are making
progress
with the vaccines and the role that's
going on it's absolutely fantastic
to be able to seek more people and make
more people happy for sub stanley 50
percent gave him the ability to bring
that warm atmosphere back into his
restaurant
and show customers the hard work they
put into the entrees
omelet cafe owner ignacio cesa can
relate to
all my hospitality friends you know it's
a big day for us and
we've been waiting for this day it's
very emotional cesa knows firsthand what
a stressful and emotional roller coaster
it's been
his employees celebrate the news it's
just you know
more money for my employees you know
you're taking them from one level to the
next level
going from 25 to 35 was pretty decent
and now going from 35 to 50 percent
it's just huge for both of stanley and
cesa revenue will definitely increase
we may be allowing more people in but we
still want to make sure that we're able
to provide a safe environment for them
so they can continue coming back in the
long term
both restaurants as well as many other
locally owned restaurants encourage you
to support them whether it's dine in
or take out they also ask you that you
order online through their websites
directly
and not through third parties if you can
reporting live in southern highlands
sally jaramillo 8 news now